good day and welcome to nature's returns
a webinar speaker series hosted by the
Yale Center for business in the
environment in partnership with the
conservation finance network at Island
Press my name is Lee Welton and I serve
as a program director here at the
conservation finance network together
with Andrew woo we will be the hosts for
your webinar today titled quantified the
new book and its implications for
conservation impact investing the Yale
Center for business in the environment
is pleased to continue nature's returns
a webinar series that addresses the
growing importance of ecosystem service
valuation and investment each
presentation is recorded and is made
available on the Yale iTunes view
channel we are also excited to share
news of a new partnership between the
Center for Business in the environment
at Yale with the conservation finance
network this initiative will provide
original content and share timely news
events and resources on conservation
finance online stay tuned for more to
come founded at Island Press in 2012 the
conservation finance network seeks to
accelerate the pace and scale of land
resource conservation restoration and
stewardship in the US through the
application of financial tools and
strategies by delivering intensive
trainings and building a network of
professionals from across the
conservation of finance and
philanthropic sectors CFN helps to
increase the financial resources
deployed for conservation so we are
pleased to have joe whitworth with us
today joe is president of the freshwater
trust an organization that protects and
restores freshwater ecosystems using
science technology and incentive based
solutions Joe's been responsible for the
organization's strategic direction for
more than a decade and has grown the
organization's budget tenfold during
that time as his book details Joe is
focused on the next generation of
conservation tools at the intersection
of Technology and finance to get results
on the ground he holds a BA from
Dartmouth and a JD from Lewis and
mark with an emphasis in natural
resources and water law for today's
session Joe will present his provocative
new island press book quantified
redefining conservation for the next
economy in which he challenges us to
recognize that a 21st century economy
demands 21st century environmental
solutions and calls for the application
of new technologies and financial
innovations to fresh water resources in
order to accelerate the pace and scale
of conservation as an added bonus we are
offering twenty percent off the book and
free shipping when you purchase through
the island press website that's island
press 0 RG using the discount code CF
and 20 as in the conservation finance
network twenty percent off CFN 20 so
before we begin the presentation we'd
like to remind our listeners that
questions are welcome and will be
directed to Joe by Andrew at the
conclusion of the talk you can type your
questions directly into the gotomeeting
chat window that you'll see in your
browser and with that we welcome joe
whitworth to nature's returns Joe I will
let you take it from here great Thank
You Lee and thank you Andrew for hosting
this and welcome to talk about the book
as we mentioned my name is joe whitworth
and i run a conservation group we're
headquartered in the pacific northwest
portland oregon is the main office and
i've been here for several years but you
know this book in many ways is is about
me making sense of how we have
progressed during my time here internal
to the organization and really how the
world has changed external to it and
what how we can tap into some things
that we really do need to tap into so
i'll i'll start by talking a little bit
about well most of us here have jobs for
but for the next few minutes I want you
to just imagine that you're in a new in
an interview and you've finished
answering all the CEOs questions and now
it's your turn so you asked you know
what were your results last year who
were the biggest competitors what are
your long-term goals how do you track
and against them what innovations will
it take to hit those where do you see
the company in the next five years what
could undermine your success any CEO
responds I'm not really sure I mean it's
it's pretty tough to to imagine that
they would respond that way because
there's almost certainly no successful
business operating today without knowing
most if not all of these things and
fundamentally understanding where they
are and where they're headed but this is
exactly the way we've been approaching
our country's environmental problems for
a while we don't precisely know our
current status or define our goals for
improving the environment we don't use
innovation and technology be fully to
help us achieve them and we don't
adequately analyze the progress that
we're making to ensure that we're
getting quantifiable results for the
money and the effort that we're putting
in and it's it's been common thinking
that if we just go at this harder and do
more the same someday it's all going to
work out and you know we've pretty much
one as an environmental movement
everything on paper but the truth is
it's not making the difference on the
ground that's needed you know and it it
hasn't always been this way I mean in
the in the 70s we saw the problem as
clear as day I mean we witnessed an
economy that had completely overreached
and went well beyond the environmental
bounds or the physical environmental
envelope in such a way the change was
demanded that led to the
you know the all of the legislation the
policy work and in in many ways the
environmental movement was a huge
innovative force we built all those
things out of thin air if you will and
they did stop a lot of bad things from
happening but even the best laws and
policies and work become outmoded when
the world ships and today we have to ask
ourselves some tough questions and be
prepared for swear some pretty tough
answers and you know are the traditional
conservation solutions that help spur
change in the 20th century enough to
move the bar here in the 21st are they
enough to address the challenges of
climate change and expanding human
impacts that we're seeing on water
quality and water quantity you know the
short answer is no and you know if you
if you took someone from the 1970s and
you dropped them on the earth today they
would see a completely different thing I
mean from from the dawn of the
environmental movement which I now would
argue is moved in is now I no longer a
movement so much as a sector but world
population has doubled to 7.2 billion
u.s. population has grown by fifty five
percent the amount of pesticides used in
the US has tripled to over a billion
pounds a year the number of worldwide
dead zones is spiraled from 32 more than
500 freshwater species have declined by
fifty percent I mean there and I of
course can go on but you know what we're
witnessing here is an era change right
before our eyes not a generational
change an era change and eras change
when tools change to better meet needs I
mean we didn't move from the Bronze Age
to the iron to iron age because we ran
out of bronze we ran we shifted because
steel was cheaper more available
stronger lighter it just work
better and we're in a similar place I
hope to where things were in the sixties
and seventies when we woke up to the
fact that the economic gains carried
real environmental costs and we needed
to rein it in we beat we build piece by
piece the slow moving gears of
bureaucracy to do exactly that but our
devotion to that apparatus is now
crushing our ability to make a
difference and that has to change so we
all know that the biosphere is the
ultimate closed loop I mean we don't
have any more water today then when the
earth opened up for business that's not
changed at all what has changed is
weather and in what condition it shows
up I mean nature causes drought but man
causes shortage and in this what you're
looking at right here is of course on
the left that the small blue sphere is
all the water on Earth including all the
freshwater and saltwater and on the
right you have that's the atmosphere so
we don't have a lot of it right so but
in half a closed-loop world and
open-ended accounting you've got some
pretty significant problems but if you
engage in a fume some closed-loop
accounting to track all the inputs and
the outputs and the leftovers that are
created by an economy you actually have
some opportunity and what's in front of
you now is the scatter graph of all the
countries in the world and then going
horizontally you have earth per person
in nineteen sixty one or two thousand
six essentially the earth per person in
terms of you know hectares per person
has been cut in half due primarily to
population growth of course and on the
going to the right you have that what is
effectively the UN poverty line it's the
hue
in human development index where you
want to be beyond that but you but we
need to be below the earth per person in
order to have something that is a
properly designed economy the striking
thing about this is that you don't have
any countries in that the high human
development box that is within the
Earth's limits and that is a bit of a
scary proposition Malcolm Preston who is
a global head of PricewaterhouseCoopers
sustainability practice makes sense it
did pretty well he's of course he's an
accountant by training but also he's a
deal guy and his point in an earlier
presentation was that all we do is more
the same were clearly in trouble but if
we properly account for inputs outputs
the leftovers the externalities created
in our economy we can actually innovate
toward the lower right-hand corner
bringing the economy back inside the
physical envelope of the environment and
he believes drive the greatest economic
opportunity in the history of mankind
and so I violently agree with Malcolm
and you know the themes of that are
certainly explored throughout the book
but you know the fact is that new
solutions that are enabled through
technologies rinoa remote sensing cloud
computing mobility data science you know
quant you know fishin seas new
transaction methods are available to us
that would unleash this the
environmental gain that we need pretty
desperately right now but they're just
out of our reach and so what we need to
do is understand it's time for a shift
and understand that the last 45 years
using the same tools and strapped
geez with some minor refinements really
need some updating if not abandonment in
order to move beyond just doing the work
to improve the environment but actually
measuring the outcomes and getting the
outcomes and you know this is after my
15 years in the conservation world I
don't see any other way for us to make
the kind of difference that I understood
that we intended to make back when the
modern environmental movement began I
mean we really have no choice to but to
go 21st century on our program and so
when I looked at the work that's out
there I looked at a lot of our work I
began to make sense of you know these
abilities five elements really began to
distill out into a framework that really
can can apply at the organizational
level at the you know at the corporate
level at the end it the the movement
level and so for me you know this idea
of quantified conservation is about
leveraging the best practices from you
know today's successful businesses and
most most significant social sector
organizations to be harnessed and
overhaul the state of our natural
resources and this is not a white paper
book I'm a very practical person have no
interest in white papers outside of as a
starting point that get that get enacted
in some way so but you know what's
ironic about these pieces and really how
things have devolved I mean you know in
the in the 70s business was always the
bad guy and the enviro swarthy
innovators but that's shifted and today
we need to take a page or two from these
so from these entrepreneurial play books
that I think can make a pretty important
difference here so they're listed here
I'm going to run through each of these
so you get a little bit better sense but
it's situational awareness outcomes
innovation in tech data and analytics
and gain those are these are the
elements of what I call quantified
conservation so the first one is
situational awareness that's it's a
military term originally and there's
kind of an easy analogy here with this
one I mean I can't see you you can't see
me but I would ask you to most of the
people on the other end of this webinar
have a phone in their pocket or within
arm's length 20 years ago you didn't and
the fact is maybe maybe 10 years ago it
was probably a blackberry but today it's
probably not a blackberry and I would
argue that blackberry lost its ground
and its success due to its inability to
keep up with market trends to pay
attention with what's going on Apple
zoom past them because they knew how to
innovate they knew how to gauge the
market and you know blackberry didn't
even see it coming I mean it's it was I
was astounded to realize that the we
didn't even have the iphone and think
until 2007 but something very similar
has happened to the environmental
movement you know in the 1970s it was
pretty easy to see what was going on and
you know when rivers are burning you of
course you know you don't miss those but
times gone on and even though we don't
see those flames the rivers are still
burning right after a generation of more
than a generation of effort under the
Clean Water Act fifty-five percent of
our nation's 3.7 stream miles are
polluted or damaged their impaired under
the Clean Water Act so that's a hint
today you know the colorado river a
river that was strong
to carve the Grand Canyon from Strome is
no longer strong enough to make it to
its own mouth the Mississippi is so
choked with fertilizers from AG runoff
that it every year it creates a dead
zone in the Gulf you know something on
the order you know six to eight thousand
square miles and and because we all want
consumer goods that are made with water
I mean the demands are our water
resources are only increasing water is
embedded in every made thing or produced
thing on earth no exceptions and its
water has been an invisible input to
build a quote valuable thing whether
it's crops or fibers or product rather
than the asset that it actually is you
know the the genes that I have on right
now or you know I took twenty nine
hundred gallons of water to spin or the
grow the cotton to spend the thread to
make the jeans and the by-products of
that if they were grown in p.m. arizona
are that you know the colorado river
basin is d water and nobody asked me
about that but that's what's happened
that's the system were working and so
you know the reality is we have to we
have to wake up to where we really are
and that's going to mean seeing things
and a little bit of seeing things for
the first time in a new light but once
we understand dad once we understand
that we were not on track we need to
start naming and chasing some big
outcomes and not more of the same
improving a little bit here there on the
margins but going after some really big
targets and so when I think of outcomes
I like to think of a larry page and his
belief in the power of 10x he wants and
expects his employees to be working on
something that can change the world and
he's looking for a thousand percent
improvement not ten percent better or
one hundred percent
better I mean 10x better and you know if
you do that you explore the very limits
of what is technically possible and the
job description that I got as I kind of
made sense of it coming out of law
school was you got to hold the line this
was the big mantra of the 19 you know
the last or the I will say the first
generation of the modern environmental
movement but holding the line is is
effectively a zero percent improvement
target and that's that's just not going
to catch us up I mean we have to find
ways to move ahead and you know we we
can knock down really big targets in
short order but we need a new kind of
clarity and commitment on where we're
going and what it's going to take to
achieve that but it's not unprecedented
maybe we you know we see this I mean
we've seen this very recently in the
murray-darling when I say recently you
know the late late 90s early 2000s
Australia the driest inhabited continent
on the face of planet you know they they
had a serious drought a drought that you
know that California hopes never comes
but you know the what we can see is it
mean it led to all kinds of things in
two thousand i think 2008 they had you
know a million tonne rice crop failure
which growing rice in the desert has
some downsides and running out of water
because you mismanage it is one of those
but you know that rice crop failure
sparked food riots in 34 countries i
mean the ripple effect of a single water
crisis in a producing region is pretty
significant and we're heading into a
time where this is not going to be all
that abnormal so we really have to get
out in front of it but what Australia
did they led to the water act in 2007
that created effectively a water budget
right there was tied to the physical
limits of the resource I mean they
reloaded their entire water rights
scheme essentially setting up
cap prorating water rights based on past
use setting aside environmental minimum
flows buying out several of those uses
that were profligate uses of water and
utilizing water markets to reallocate
value reallocate water from low value
high water crops to high-value low water
crops it was not without its difficulty
was not without its bumps but it's
working and it's I think there are
several of themes here that we can
extract from Australia and we can see
those coming to a place near us I think
not the not too different future but
Australia obviously had to act and they
had to have a big outcome you know in
the face of crisis but we can act in
advance of crisis to right and that's
where innovation comes in I'm convinced
the old tools alone will not get it done
and the way we are going to augment that
is going to be enabled a lot through
innovation you know for too long we've
been we've been telling ourselves that
we do just more the right thing will win
but the results are telling us that's
just not true we got to work smarter
innovation is a big piece of that if you
look at about any successful company out
there they've pulled from just this
vault of vision and possibility that
it's almost the stuff of science fiction
Google's making the self-driving cars
Tesla's are faster than Corvettes kids
are flying drones you know it Apple's
has this talking into our watches like
Spock or Dick Tracy and no matter how
you feel about these unique innovations
when it comes to saving our world's
water supply we could take a page out of
the innovation but and there are plenty
of pages to choose from now an obvious
one is we need to understand the state
of our watersheds in real time I mean
I'm not going to say that techno gadgets
are going to save the environment and
fix the economy they're not there
they're enabling device
but you know this map I showed earlier
this map took more than a decade to put
together right I mean the fact that it's
all red and these are the you know the
the millions of stream miles that are
there that are impaired I mean that's
scary in itself but scarier than that to
me is the is this you know how long it
took I'm going to jump out here very
quickly and then hopefully jump back in
very quickly but the you know when you
have a map that literally took ten years
to make and then a couple more years to
crunch it and put it all together that
is real time in the environment it's it
can be a decade old right and that's
just not okay when every 90 minutes an
army of increasingly low-cost satellites
are circling the globe and sending
images back to us that have greater
resolution than anything that we have
seen before right and so this is the
kind of a thing that we've got to start
no I thought you know it's funny I don't
have anybody to blame for my a-v here so
i just have to say it is my fault the
clunkiness but we can get a new type of
information in a way that we just
couldn't before and we need to we're
doing it a little bit but we need to
really pick it up because if we don't
use it we're really lagging I mean my
dad was a carpenter and a you know such
an obvious thing to use I mean it
reminds me when we would go fix leak in
a roof you know it was it's simple
problem simple solution he could pad
pretty quickly and the job was done but
it didn't know where it was or he'd
never looked he couldn't fix it ever
unless you know we were we just went out
and tarred the whole roof and in a lot
of ways that's what we're trying to do
and it's it's just not happening at the
rate that it needs to I mean we've got
many organizations are starting to
utilize this technology we already have
software that can increase dramatically
the pace of permitting projects to
restore rivers it's that has
historically been labor intense
manualized sequential because all the
agencies had to have different they do
have different statutory mandates
politics operating procedures but all of
that stuff can be done simultaneously
now I mean if you we can input the
agency's requirements into an algorithm
with you know that operates under
comprehensive sideboards and we can
process permits in seconds instead of
days or months or years in the same way
the turbotax you know revolutionized how
we filed taxes or how we can get any
book ever written in any language
anywhere in the world in 60 seconds in
technology is it's not the answer but it
is an enabler we can streamline
processes without short changing the
environment now time can be saved
dollars can be stretched results can be
better than the question really isn't
can we do it the question is why are we
not doing it you know if if it I mean I
do believe it's come down to a
straightjacket that we'd built for
ourselves and we're too tired or what I
call conservation 1 point 0 and there
are a lot of people that are you know
from those waning days that came of age
and those containing days 1 point 0 that
would totally disagree with the argument
that I'm making about innovating and
using technology to get at the problems
but if we just put down the weapons of
procedural attack and pick up some
technology and invest some effort I
think we'd get further down the line
fixing some of our freshwater resources
and giving them a better future so
technology requires insight it requires
context I mean in it of itself it's not
enough I mean we need data and we need
analytics and today there is an
incredible amount of publicly available
data floating around on the web I mean
every day we create two and a half
quintillion new bytes of data that's
what 25,000 billions or 20 I mean it's a
lot and if each byte were a penny that's
enough pennies to completely cover the
earth five times every single day and in
a week that's you know it's an inch and
in a month it's you know up to your knee
and in a year it's 20 plus feet deep and
it's only accelerating and the question
in my mind about data as I started to
understand it is how are we using this
um massive amount on a data to really
deal with these problems and you know
most companies right seventy-three
percent of them use data to increase
revenue eighty-four percent of
executives use data to make their make
better decisions but those that don't
sound a lot like the loser CEO that we
interviewed with a little local here
right I mean so as we look at our
environmental issues we I imagine you
know how data analysis can be made to
work it has right I mean an easy example
sonoma county water agency in california
did it you know it teamed up with IBM
they developed the water management
system that helps them identify leaky
water pipes in real time to prepare them
quickly and efficiently but it also
gives them data about water usage water
quality weather climate so they can
begin to water or allocate the water
more efficiently and just take care of
it in a more intentional way they need
that right now so and you know my
organization we we're going
even a little more granular and I may
have a chance to go into this a little
bit later on but we found that by
combining aerial images with existing
data we can identify very specific
conservation projects on specific plots
of land that are going to go the
farthest fastest toward restoring our
streams and our rivers in the you know
for the cheapest cheapest in terms of
dollars and time but we can guarantee
that the right actions are happening in
the right place is to make the biggest
amount of difference for the least
amount of money and we track it like
crazy but that real-time knowledge
allows us quicktime action so the other
challenge here is how big the problem is
and I'm not naive to the fact that these
are the issues facing freshwater
ecosystems are just massive but to match
them we're going to need scale we're
going to need to restore entire River
River corridors not just pieces here
there if we want fishable swimmable
drinkable waters and the immutable truth
of all this is that restoration takes
some serious cash need to fix our rivers
we're going to need to likely double our
conservation work force and the good
news is we can go a long way to doing
that with the cash we're already
spending I mean federal government
spends more than six billion dollars a
year on programs targeted at enhancing
Water Resources states and
municipalities throw down maybe another
two but almost none of them really know
what they're getting and just because
you spend a dollar doesn't mean it's
doing any good and I would argue when we
spend a dollar on conservation in this
country we get way less than a dollars
worth of benefit from that and so how do
we track that I mean we track it by
attaching every dollar spent to you know
getting standardized units of
environmental of uplift measured
benefits for ecosystems and this is how
we will transform environmental spending
it lets us revolutionize that the
officially not just of you know or make
environmental markets happen which can
happen but that's not the only thing
here i am not a markets guy i'm engaged
in them because i'm very interested in
what i see is the upside but public
funds are also important here you know
philanthropy of course and industry
dollars that are spent making up for
those environmental impacts what
ecosystem services will allow us to do
is we will shift from spending billions
to spending billions write me an
ecosystem services have been the holy
grail of conservation for a while now
it's white paper rich but transaction
poor area of work and but with the
advent of more precise environmental
accounting and procedures we are getting
to a place where we can standardize the
legal biological and transactional
mechanics so that we can step beyond
merely monetizing the environment as
many of the ecosystem service market
deals have been to date and create a
require actual environmental gains every
single time this will mean a shift from
funding project ideas and a long list of
hope for results that you know grant
makers and governments and those that
impact watershed function what will need
to happen as we will need to shift
everything so they're going to purchase
outcomes that render clear and
quantified gains and we can do this
because we can we can x-ray nature now
in a way that we couldn't not so long
ago even two years ago we couldn't do
the things that we can do now and so if
if a grant maker receives
proposals both of them involve planning
five thousand trees for the same prize
in the same piece of river it's hard for
them to choose which one to fund because
they look a lot of like on paper but if
those proposals are required to quantify
the outcomes of the proposed project and
return the money if they don't deliver
the funders can see clearly that one
project say can reduce sediment by fifty
thousand kilograms in a year versus 500
kilograms in a year then the choice
becomes really clear really strategic
and really targeted and so whether
you're you know whether you're spending
a dollar whatever your motivations are
whether for conservation purposes market
purposes permitting purposes whatever we
only pay for results mean we need to
make that shift if we want to stretch
the current conservation dollars and
attract new capital and workforce into
properly design durable environmental
markets that's the way we ensure that
the environment makes a game with every
single transaction and that's that's
what it's going to take to turn all
those red lines to blue and I think you
know I mean I want to bring this down
you know so we can get into some
questions but the you know if we engage
these elements we can put ourselves in a
position to start getting after these
and you need situational awareness
understand where we're at we need to get
very clear and bold on the outcomes
we're after we need to engage the
innovation I mean I one of the striking
things I mean I do view innovation not
just as technology but new transactions
and so forth but if we applied the
collective intellectual wattage and
committed elbow grease that the folks
engaged in this work have if we you know
did that in an aligned
just way over the next 10 years I got to
believe we would see some of the
innovations that we've seen out of
technology over the last and I think we
we need to do that we of course use data
analytics to make sense of it and if we
can embed this concept of environmental
game that can account for our impacts
impacts outputs we're going to be able
to start making some some real progress
and you know one of the things I got to
do which I loved doing I looked across
there were a lot of surprising positives
across every field truly sector and
primarily I looked at agriculture
business philanthropy government and the
environmental movement itself and there
were a lot of great things going on but
the innovation was the exception not the
rule and you know a lot of this has to
do with design thinking and I but
favorite quote out of all this whole
deal came from a guy Jim Jannard who was
a youngster engaged in motocross and he
noticed that when he rode rode his bike
that he would belong to the race the
more he would sweat the more he would
sweat the slippier his uh his hand grip
Scott and so he said to himself you know
what I need to do is I need to design a
hand grip that actually gets grippier
the sweaty ER I get which was of course
contra to everything that everybody had
thought been possible to date he of
course figured that out and created the
oakley hand grip a while ago that went
on to let him into of course glasses and
lenses and his quote that really kind of
just hit me right in the jaw was
everything in the world can and will be
made better the only questions are when
and by whom
and I think that unless everybody who's
working in this sector picks it up and
says the answers to those questions are
now and by us I think we're going to
wake up or we're going to wake up in ten
years because we will be staying asleep
and we're going to realize that we are
not getting it done and we're not going
to get it done and I think you know for
me what's the point unless we do that I
I'm a big believer in fixing problems
and I think we've got now a real
opportunity to do that so hopefully we
got some questions Andrew and and we can
run run through some of those sounds
great Joe thank you very much group
presentation now I'd like to dig deeper
into quantified conservation as it
relates to increasing capital flows for
conservation in your book you talk about
quantified conservation as an enabler of
environmental markets where companies
can buy or sell say units of
Environmental Quality now one issue that
arises is the locality of many
environmental benefits like water
quality which in turn limits the number
of investors willing to pay for
environmental benefits and thus limits
the size of the market to what extent
can quantified conservation address
these inherent limitations and could you
provide a local example that has
addressed this challenge in any way yeah
a great question and again you know I'm
not a markets guy I'm a conservationist
and I do believe that if we really want
to fix these things we do need to
increase capital flow to these issues
and it's got to be done in a way that
finance wants to play and I think that
both the conservation side and the
finance side are really slowly starting
to speak each other's language and what
quantified conservation does is it
provides a group want the lingua franca
the units of environmental uplift that
can enable
uh the money to do business with the
environment in a way that it just hasn't
been done precisely before so you hit on
an issue locality of benefits water is
of course a different medium than say
carbon I mean you have a bath fungible
you know atmosphere where you can plant
here and get credit there and it's all
roughly the same in some sense so water
is different right but I think that the
way you take care of it you could we
could set up an environmental market for
water quality as large as the
Mississippi basin Mississippi the
Missouri Mississippi Ohio systems could
all play in Drey there is complexity to
that and you have to you have to use
discounting so that if you are in st.
Louis and you buy something upstream
rest the environmental credits generated
upstream for either decreasing nitrates
or phosphorous or cooling the watershed
you can we can track those things now
the landowner upon whose land that
project is done would be receiving full
full payment for that but depending on
how far you are from where your impact
is you can essentially you can get a
discounted credit rate so you could have
you know if it's right next door you
could potentially get a hundred percent
credit if it's you know 50 miles away
maybe you get seventy percent if it's a
hundred miles away you can maybe get
twenty-five percent whatever the right
the right way to build in those
assumption and discount rates to
facilitate greater trade what we want to
have happen is get the action on the
ground and what what I discovered in the
book that you know those that have
impacts really don't I mean this is
within reason ability they don't care so
much how much it costs as long as they
can plan for it and they have sir
and they can foresee and build into
their budgets how much it's going to
cost and they can do it on a timeline
that matters and there is you know with
the ability to unit eyes the environment
for these different parameters we can do
that now we can also there is a great
need for accounting that is done
straight across the board transparency
is huge and they're kind of non you know
they're they're non negotiables we have
to have these things the the reality is
we can account for a lot of complexity
while still creating something that is
very simple for all the users and you
know if you think that's not true the
next time you break your your iPhone's
you know the cover your iPhone and
you're trying to replace that you can
see how complex that phone is on the
inside but to you the user it's pretty
easy on the outside and we have to make
make it that way so there's a lot of
work that needs to be done we have built
a transaction model here where we've
done a handful of these deals but at the
very the simplest model is the one that
we did on the Rogue River under the
Clean Water Act I mean we live in salmon
country so cool water is an important
important need these fish have as they
migrated there was a city as all cities
and municipalities do they have to treat
everything that goes down every pipe and
so when you treat it when you treat that
a lot of times you have to heat it up
and because temperature can be a
pollutant under the Clean Water Act do
to you know fishable requirements they
had to cool it down before returning it
to the waterway now historically they've
only had one option and that is you know
a great cooling tower or some kind of a
built solution and so they had you know
that's a capital capital project and
what they were looking this is a town of
about a hundred thousand people they
were looking at a twenty million a 21
million dollar deal
and that's exactly what they would have
done except for we had completed an
accounting process counting on the
environment process with all the
stakeholders scientists agencies and so
forth and so we we knew that if you
engaged in specific restoration on
specific types of land you can render
specific amounts of kilocalories now in
that deal they had an impact of 300
million kilocalories per day which is a
free you know it's pretty typical that's
how how we track these things under the
Clean Water Act I mean kilocalories the
thermal unit essentially rather than
having them pay for 300 million
kilocalories a day in the using gray
infrastructure we use natural
infrastructure in a quantified bit way
and we are building actually a little
more than 600 million kilocalories per
day that will cool the watershed in any
given watershed the Sun is the biggest
thermal input and so to combat that we
used you know shade and so you know all
of that work was done according to the
rules that were rules models assumptions
that were set up by the regulating
entities and ultimately third-party
certified put on a registry and are
completely viewable now so and the way
it worked financially we were able to
build a kilocalorie for I don't know six
and a half cents or something like that
and sell it for not ten cents and
essentially be able to save them money
get that you save the entity money get
compliance for the regulator's put local
folks to work nursery native nurseries
are expanding down there we have local
restoration professionals that are now
doing this work we're renting or leasing
ground from landowners to grow bushels
of nature under 20 year contracts and
best of all the environment wins because
even though we're only
counting the temperature benefits of
shade the trees and the plants are doing
much more they're native to that sub
base and so they're helping out the
wildlife but they are stabilizing the
bank which you know those pounds of
sediment can be quantified they are
taking up nutrients which can be
quantified they are also sequestering
carbon and you know there's there are a
lot of benefits beyond the one that
actually was used in the transaction so
from an environmental perspective it's a
winner going away we have a lot more
work to do and so what we have also done
is we work with federal agencies and
others to take and in a quantified way
engage in actions that will result in a
big biological response from the species
which are threatened under the
Endangered Species Act down there and
the point is to bring all of these
resources to bear so that we can get a
biological response but there is a
financial proponent I mean we we look
out at the the nutrient market just in
the northwest the nutrient temperature
market that would recycle something
something like every 10 years he is
approaching a billion-dollar market that
town of a hundred thousand people as a
firm operates in a permit under the
Clean Water Act there are 200,000 such
permits under the Clean Water Act and so
that is where you have a need for
natural infrastructure that can be
quantified and then tracked and used as
the basis for really driving a
nationwide environmental water quality
trading market sounds great thank you
now in terms of enabling investors we
have a question from Lee yourself in the
book you talk about quantified
conservation as a means of enabling
investors be they be investment fund
managers or philanthropic PRI makers to
target impact what trends are you
observing with these investors is
quantified conservation
to unlock new sources of capital and
bringing your investors to the field
well yeah I will say boy there is a lot
of what I would kind of categorize as
the right kind of money that is ready to
go but they need deals I mean part of my
motivation for this book was to bounce
have the alarm to the conservation mean
you say you know there are a lot of new
players out there and we need to we need
to meet them at least halfway this is
not simply a you know an old grant
making process this is a different deal
the efficiency of markets the the
discipline of investments really has had
a great benefit to us internally to find
ways to increase survival rates and
decrease our costs so that we can make
more margin so we can take that margin
and pour it into more conservation
efforts where those market signals don't
exist but you know for me what's been
astounding is just the sheer growth in
interest both philosophically but also
you know the funds that are being
created and two degree being deployed on
you know one-off kinds of deals is
pretty significant and I think that
trend is going to only continue and so
you know the world has changed and I
talked about this in the book the world
has changed from that 1955 model we're
on one end of the spectrum you had the
purely commercial and on the other end
of the spectrum you had the purely
charitable you know so you know you had
the CEO of the chemical plant who would
make a lot of money and then he would
you know or she would give the money to
the to the Opera or whatever what's
happening is our sensibilities are
changing we're starting to see people
migrate into the middle that's why
Toyota has a Prius that's why seventh
generation has sustainable cleaning
products and and interestingly now
SC Johnson also has those kinds of
Cheerios is GMO free and so we're
starting to see an integration of
environmental sensibilities with the
economy and the point of this book is to
get them even further integrated in a
way where we don't have any slippage of
the gears and you know I I see a lot of
great opportunity in front of us but we
have a lot of standardization that needs
to occur and there has been either
either an inertia or a reticence on the
side of most environmentalists and
conservationists partly because they're
preoccupied with doing what they've been
doing but I want to break those barriers
down and say hey look there's a great
opportunity here if we can get our side
of this equation together and here are
the tools to do it I'm glad you
mentioned this whole idea of
standardization I'd really like to build
on the discussion about that so you know
as you know in the quest to quantify
conservation and the environmental
impacts of private investment one thing
we've witnessed in recent trends is the
sheer diversity in measures and metrics
each of which you know are relevant in
different ecosystems or of interest to
different stakeholders so you know as
you stated like it sounds like you feel
there should be a need for a
standardized system of metrics for
Environmental Quality but in your view
who is responsible or best equipped to
create the system is it scientists NGOs
private investors my impressions are
that it should be a joint effort but as
a means of balancing various stakeholder
values but I'm curious to hear your
thoughts on the matter as to how the
standardization should go about yeah
this is my view this is probably the key
issue that we have to resolve and first
off I will say this is going to be an
iterative process you know we will have
a version one point
oh and we will have a version you know
25 but we have to start somewhere and
what we're what we're experiencing is
you know that we don't have we have all
these like Civil War currencies we have
been measuring things for a long time
but we haven't been transacting on
things for a long time and so what you
have are these great you know the great
uniqueness is of the various watersheds
and so forth there in there but you know
we looked at this there are only 16 ways
to fix a river that's it there's not
6,000 there are 16 ways and we're
looking for form and function and we
have surrogate indicators that are
available and what we know is that you
know if every deal is a one-off if every
deal is bespoke deal I mean bespoke
doesn't scale we need the standard set
of currencies and we need them sooner
rather than later we don't have to have
them complete we need the easy ones
first you know we have found temperature
is a pretty easy one to track and
quantify we have found that once you
move into sediments are pretty easy
nutrients are a little more difficult
but we can calculate them we're working
on those there is a there's a national
network for water quality standards that
is coming on well they're starting to do
some work and it is as you suggest a
joint effort with NGOs scientists
agencies and you know I think that what
we what we and it's further down the
line than we think we have a I think
within the environmental community
there's a discomfort of well we don't
know if it's going to work well I don't
know if I you know if we can trust it I
mean you know this is you know I'm
trained as a lawyer you know we have
some scientists you know this is talking
about using you know money finance which
is you know a very gray area for me
the in the conservation community it's a
different set of language it's a
different set of tools and there is a an
unease with that same is true with
technology but the truth is we can do
these things and we need to find a way
to break through so it's a you know I'm
okay and I think we need to be okay with
not getting it 100 percent right now
we're going to fall down and skin our
knees and that's fine you know one of
the big thrusts and I didn't want to
spend a lot of time on the book at all
talking about the problem because we
spend about eighty-five percent always
talking about the problem in
conservation or environmentally focused
books I wanted this to be about
solutions and conclusions and we need to
start down the path because if we're
honest with ourselves we are way off
track from an environment perspective
and we we do need new tools that's kind
of where I said look the world changed
it's not that weird it's not the work
bad at what we do or we're lazy it's
just the world change and so we have to
change with it so you know we need those
currencies we finished a joint regional
recommendations effort with EPA a set of
state dq's out here in the West and you
know we came out of that with least a
blueprint starting point that can be
tailored to local conditions in a way
that we can start in a very principled
way conducting transactions that are you
know the first deals like the fifth feel
the 500th deal and that's the way that's
the only way markets are going to be
made we have seen the monetization of
the environment in you know in
Chesapeake is my primary example that I
run through in the book you know deals
have been done money's been made impacts
have been had but the environment
doesn't seem like it's getting much out
of the deal and our thesis is that the
environment certainly can
and it can get you can do it in a very
efficient way and markets can be enabled
but markets are like rockets they they
need to be I mean Rockets can take you
to unbelievable places places you've
never imagined going but they have to be
built right very soundly and they have
to be targeted right you know if you
have one that's not put together well
and you got it you know leaning on its
side when you blast off it's going to
tear across the landscape and create a
lot of bad things markets are the same
way and so I talk a lot about how to
properly design a market and what those
elements are in the book some of those i
just mentioned here but the
standardization piece is the big piece
and we we can we can do this in a way
that really does make a big difference
environmentally while also generating a
lot of capital flow toward the problems
that we want fixed like the dead zone
like getting colorado to reach the sea
like recovering the fish out here like
fixing the Chesapeake we can do these
things we've got to set it up right and
then get going on it and with that thank
you Joe that concludes the talk on the
new book quantified once again we would
like to thank joe whitworth for joining
us today if you wish to review a
recording of this webinar please visit
the yale center for business and the
environment website or access the
recording through the yale iTunes
University podcast thank you for joining
us until next time this is andrew woo
from the yale center for business and
environment in collaboration with lee
Welton the conservation finance network